[Música]
nosotros ahora pasamos a hablar con
nuestro segundo invitado del día y le
planteamos la siguiente situación Y es
que la oficina de Washington para
asuntos latinoamericanos Hola dice que
los precios de la hoja de Coca han
bajado alrededor de un 60% en el último
año y Colombia pese a ser primer
productor mundial de cocaína también
está viendo una baja en el precio de la
hoja de coca una situación que se
replica en otros países de la región la
disminución de los precios muestra que
el ilícito de los narcocultivos se
estaría reconfigurando Ahora sí vamos a
conversar sobre este tema con Germán
Andrés clavijo él es coordinador
Regional del sistema integrado de
monitoreo de cultivos ilícitos de la
oficina de las Naciones Unidas contra la
droga y el delito 1 para la región
andina y el conur también nos acompañan
el estudio nuestra especialista en
economía Daniela Blandón bienvenida
muchas Gracias Rosa empezamos
planteándole Hola buenas Buenos días
precisamente por qué baja el precio de
la coca aquí en América Latina
Buenos días Muchas gracias por este
espacio la oficina de las Naciones
Unidas
específicamente del sistema integral
agradece este espacio para aclarar estas
dinámicas del mercado de la hoja que
están ocurriendo en Colombia
efectivamente lo que has mencionado es
es algo que hemos visto en la oficina
desde hace aproximadamente un año se ha
evidenciado a través de la información
de nuestras oficinas de campo que hay
una dinámica que está ocurriendo
respecto de los mercados de hoja de coca
y cocaína esto puede estar asociado
específicamente a tres factores el
primer factor está asociado al aumento
récord del potencial de producción de
clorhidrato de cocaína en 2021
que se evidenció los tres países no solo
en Colombia sino en los países
tradicionalmente cultivadores de Coca
Colombia
mostró un 43% de incremento en la
siembra de Coca respecto de área Perú de
31%
policía del cuatro por ciento este es
uno de los primeros factores digamos que
tendríamos que tener presente la
cantidad de El potencial de producción
de Claridad de cocaína que hay
disponible el segundo está asociado a
estas disputas que existen entre los
grupos armados ilegales presentes en el
territorio colombiano y el crimen
organizado trasnacional porque la
dinámica del mercado comenzó a cambiar
estos grupos comenzaron a entrar a
Colombia para hacer propias hacer sus
propias negociaciones esto generó pues
unas disputaciones un escenario de
incertidumbre lo que lleva el tercer
factor que es la escasez de compradores
en estas zonas que se han presentado
esto puede estar haciendo que la
dinámica del mercado y la hoja de Coca
cocaína pues presenta estas variaciones
de las cuales tú has hablado Quiero
preguntarle si si es que Bueno usted ha
hablado de una técnica una especie de
tecnificación
de este proceso de producción pero
quiero preguntarle también si el la
demanda también tiene algo que ver están
ha habido cambios en la demanda en
países como Estados Unidos o en Europa
que lleven a esta situación
bueno en primer lugar
el coordinador del sistema integrado acá
tenemos un área que se dedica
específicamente
a los análisis asociados a la demanda
sin embargo desde la oficina lo que
hemos visto y el último informe mundial
de cocaína lo que ve es un cambio en la
dinámica del mercado de la cocaína con
una contracción del digámoslo de de la
oferta que de perdón de la demanda que
existe en el mercado norteamericano y
una ampliación de esta demanda en el
mercado europeo puede ser que esto
también esté dinamizando los precios no
solo en Colombia sino en la región y le
quisiera preguntar a Germán algo que que
usted ya mencionaba en la primera
respuesta y es precisamente esta
reconfiguración de la que usted habló
del crimen organizado internacional
precisamente Cómo se está reconfigurando
Este mercado ilícito
bien lo primero que tengo que mencionar
está asociado a la situación que ocurrió
en Colombia específicamente después del
acuerdo de paz hay algunos territorios
que tenían una hegemonía por un grupo
armado en el cual el grupo armado tenía
una regulación del precio este precio
hacía que indiferentemente del del
tamaño del productor agropecuario con
coca que existiera en el territorio se
aseguraba la compra de estos insumos de
la hoja o de la pasta base sin embargo
con la salida de este grupo armado por
el acuerdo de paz comienzan a ingresar
otros grupos que disputen por este nuevo
mercado entonces esa situación está
ocurriendo en Colombia eso ha hecho que
grupos de crimen organizado
transnacional comiencen a llegar a zonas
de producción en Colombia eso antes no
se veía antes de este acuerdo por un
lado hay otra reconfiguración que hemos
visto y que es una alerta que yo
inaudicí ha hecho a nivel mundial y es
este nuevo escenario en donde lo que
vemos es que las incautaciones de pasta
base
y de clorhidrato han aumentado en la
región eso que implica que el crimen
organizado transnacional está
reconfigurándose para desde los países
productores como Colombia Perú y Bolivia
exportar pasta minimizando los riesgos
en el caso de que ocurran digamos
incautaciones y haciendo procesos de
transformación a clorhidrato en otros
países de la región en estos países
sea digamos mucho más limitada respecto
de los insumos y sustancias químicas que
se presentan después Algo que queremos
llamar la atención Germán y toda esta
situación que implica para los
campesinos que finalmente son los que
están produciendo y que esta ha sido su
actividad durante décadas y cómo es la
situación hoy en el campo para estas
personas a quienes les ha bajado el
precio de este insumo que es el insumo
principal para la cocaína
Mira las informaciones que tenemos de
campo efectivamente evidencian que el
hay una dinámica del mercado de los
precios y esto implica que estos
pequeños productores estén demandandole
al gobierno proyectos alternativos
digámoslo proyectos de sustitución de
cultivos en este momento el gobierno es
como el colombiano están adelantando un
plan de seguridad alimentaria que ya Es
evidente ya inclusive hay una resolución
que muestra que el gobierno de Colombia
está llegando con pagos adicionales para
asegurar seguridad alimentaria a estas
personas que va digamos lo acompañados
Pues de un proyecto productivo y además
se han adicionado proyectos de
desarrollo alternativo no solo las
familias que ya estaban vinculadas sino
otras familias que se quieren incorporar
también hay que hablar del precio porque
no es lo mismo el precio de la hoja de
coca en el en el terreno que el precio
de la cocaína en el mercado
internacional qué está pasando ahí hay
una brecha muy alta entre estos dos
valores
pues efectivamente cuando
tomas el el la hoja de Coca la extraes
tiene un precio no un precio que
dependiendo de la zona en Colombia o en
las regiones productoras puede puede
variar sin embargo Cuando haces el
proceso de transformación a base ese
precio digamos ya tiene un cambio
también en zona de producción y cuando
lo llevas a zonas de digamos lo de
frontera o en donde ya comienza a llevar
las zonas de exportación cambia este
precio lo que lo que hemos visto es que
pues efectivamente el en este momento la
dinámica de los precios está asociada a
los derivados de la hoja de la hoja como
tal y los derivados de la hoja que son
específicamente pasta y base en Colombia
aproximadamente el 60% de los
cultivadores llega hasta pasta y base de
ahí para allá digámoslo en el tema de
clorhidrato de cocaína ya está más
asociado
tráfico lo que hemos evidenciado en los
informes que nos han enviado de
digámoslo de en la región está asociado
a que también en el precio del
clorhidrato se ha visto una dinámica en
los mercados internacionales Germán
Andrés lastimosamente se nos acaba el
tiempo para continuar abordando esta
cuestión pero muchísimas gracias por
acercarnosla aquí en France 24
bien muchas gracias de parte de la
oficina de las Naciones Unidas contra la
droga y el delito del proyecto City
estamos dispuestos a continuar
presentando datos con base en evidencia
científica para la construcción de
nuevas alternativas
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes Daniela nos
vemos en minutos
[Música]